foreign
hello everybody before we get into the
show uh I want to talk to you about
adamandeve.com
whether you're shopping for yourself or
someone special Adam and Eve will have
the perfect gifts and with an amazing
deal
get just about any item or almost any
item at 50 off plus free shipping when
you use this podcast exclusive code
Lifeline at checkout
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e that's 50 off an
adventurous new toy a slip reluber
almost anything else you desire our
podcast listeners will get 50 off almost
any item oh this is crazy dude so 50 off
and then also free shipping that equals
out to be more than 50 off if you do the
math wow more pleasure in the bedroom is
the gift that keeps on giving treat
yourself treat your partner life is too
short to not enjoy yourself also it's
very discreet right it shows up to your
door in uh it's it's unmarked packaging
yeah it doesn't matter what you choose
yeah it's all discreet like that that's
really great not only will you save
money on gas movies and date night
dinners out but this is the item that
will continue to save you money deliver
tons of fun and satisfaction go to
adamandeve.com select any one item use
code lifeline that's
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e this is an exclusive
offer specific to this podcast so if you
found this podcast definitely use this
and be sure to support our show and use
this code Lifeline to get you not just
the 50 off but also the 100 free
shipping that's code Lifeline go to
adamandeve.com right now
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello hello hello hello hello
[Music]
what we could also do is I could go and
do like a city
and do stand up and the night before we
do a live show for Lifeline in that same
ah and then the night before we do our
Lifeline show people ask us [ __ ] and we
do it in a theater and then the next
night I just do stand up Lifeline live
yeah we could do literally a live live
in person in person right not just
virtually like we do which we are going
to do another one uh soon here yeah yeah
yeah yeah you might like that and you
can make some money
um yeah dude you know anyway
oh this is back now okay all right so um
who do you think has a better outfit on
now me
why don't you like it because I think it
it makes you feel constricted and you
don't have higher energy want to bet no
jerking guys off the guys are like this
whoa whoa so strong well we definitely
have to bleep that out because it's the
first minute of the episode and we'll
get demonetized so um
oh you need nobody likes you that the
baby boy
Adam Sandler
December 11th you guys it's December
11th get your merch at lifelinemerch.com
it makes great for holiday season and
this is pretty much the last time you
can do it uh before and and still get it
for Christmas Yes um so go to live uh
lifelinemerch.com right that's what it
is
and uh you can also uh go to
lifewatchlifeline.com if you have a
descript if you have a um a question you
click the link in the description watch
lifeline.com and you can also do
one-on-one advice sessions with my
brother here at matalia.com so we be
loving it and uh then I am also you
could also gift tickets I will be uh
doing stand-up in San Diego no uh
January 7th I will be in Portland Oregon
January 20th Seattle Washington Lakeland
Florida Jacksonville Sugarland Texas New
Orleans New York New York Kansas City
Springfield Missouri Midland Texas
Minneapolis Minnesota Columbus Ohio
Boise Idaho among a bunch of other dates
go to Crystal go to chrislea.com and get
those tickets and uh yeah and welcome to
Lifeline guys hey welcome back to
Lifeline everybody welcome back dude we
really appreciate you guys listening we
know we just want to be a staple in your
household you know what I mean we love
having this the Sunday podcast this is
your Sunday podcast you you just you
wake up a little later than normal you
have some breakfast you make some
scrambled eggs and you sip that coffee
you just listen to us give advices isn't
that right allow us to be a staple in
your life you will not regret it wow the
worst sales pitch of all time allow us
to be a staple in your life you will not
regret that's like the regret it I say
it like that that's like the the world
ended and then it's pre-apocalyptic and
then this faction took over and that's
the and they play an image of you on TV
saying that and everyone like looks up
and watches it right right you know
under one like suppressive and you're
the talking piece but it's not even you
it's someone else using an image of you
and you already know oh oh you died a
long time ago because I'm a figure of
influence they want it to look like me
and it's me behind the scenes because
I'm the smart one okay but I'm the one
everybody loves but I'm the one that
everyone should love because I'm you
know I'm misunderstood and the thing is
I used you even though I was the one
that was the righteous one and you used
me because I'm the voice of the people
and the people love me because people
are idiots
understood nope yep so
Nader nadir
me no Suriname deer it's just another
way to say no I mean nadir means like a
low point but it does I know that uh but
also an Armenian kid that I would be in
high school with Maynard hey bro hey hey
I'm nadir nice to meet you oh yeah for
sure yeah yeah hey
hey
where you get that shirt dog I like that
uh who did you have in your grade I had
Garo I had Narco Garo uh [ __ ] Mortal
Kombat narbe narbeh narbe was sick dude
Garo always had like so much money well
I mean dude but no he was like 14. yeah
but he had like that's how his dad three
thousand dollars three thousand in high
school pocket yeah I mean he had banked
that guy it was probably 40 bucks you
just didn't know what money looked like
oh dude I knew what money looked like
dude that's how his dad showed him love
you know hey take this hey take this I I
love you take this instead of me telling
you I love you that's hilarious if
that's how [ __ ] the dad was but narbe
was the [ __ ] though narbera was like a
legitimately cool guy I remember narbe
no you don't I do you do yeah I remember
you talk about narbe I remember I know
narbay's face Norbert was sick he had
this he didn't like to drink yeah he
didn't like to tell people he didn't
drink oh so he would get alcohol at
parties and then just like do the thing
where you walk backwards and pour it out
behind you oh wow and then like yeah I I
I've done that before I got so sick and
tired of people telling me like that
sure why don't you drink why do you
drink that I just hold a beer all
[ __ ] night it was so annoying yeah
you and Norbert pees in a pot narbe and
Chris like a children's book not being
Chris why are you not drinking narbe
well because people make people make fun
of me so I act like it
um do you know how to spell narbe
n-a-r-b-a no n-a-r-b-e
and accent and H yeah yeah
um so yeah I had you know those guys
were Armenian or Persian I mean the
person's not a thing anymore Persia
doesn't exist well but that's Iran now
I mean my friend Sam is Persian
no but he means I know I know he means
something else yeah okay I mean he knows
he means it I'm not saying he doesn't
know what he's talking about so what's
the movie Prince of Persia then Jake
gyllenhall's not Persian Persia used to
be a thing and Persia is something that
people from that area if they have like
a deep love of where they're free to do
which I do like originally they say
they're Persian so Jake Gyllenhaal that
was whitewashing they would never cast
him now I mean they're 100 completely in
fact I can't believe he hasn't been
canceled after the fact it definitely
would be I've thought about this exact
thing yeah more than once a person yeah
and it's amazing that that that still
stands because that really wasn't that
long ago no it wasn't it was like eight
years ago maybe dude I was with my tour
manager and somebody was trying to
reference Jake Gyllenhaal and and they
said have you ever seen that movie and
it was a movie Jack Johnson Hall was in
and my and and my tour manager goes like
this he says oh yeah it's with that
[ __ ] guy from Prince of Persia and I
was like that's what the [ __ ] oh Jake
Joe Knows like yeah but did Spider-Man
go home or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
yeah I guess now yeah but yeah truly
yeah that's weird um yeah so but uh yeah
I I Sam shikle islami and and his
brother were the two I mean Persians
that I [ __ ] well that's his brother
solar was the one in my grade yeah and
then uh love those dudes they're down
for they're down for whatever Sam's down
for whatever dude if I had to kill
someone Sam would be like hey don't do
it I'll do it yeah yeah I don't see or
talk to solar anymore but Sam yeah it's
great well that's because when I'm when
I have a homie yeah that [ __ ] runs deep
dude my homies Run Deep and I do not
stop chilling with the homies that's
true you hang out with the weirdest
people
and that you never stop hanging out with
those I never did if somebody's a homie
they're a homie with me you understand
how do they prove their homie them time
I'll say it time time and do you
you know what I mean like I I basically
I feel like friendships are [ __ ] up
nowadays you know it's all for show it's
all fake especially with the internet
and like I've been in Hollywood and
obviously I've been [ __ ] thrown under
the bus and backstabbed and [ __ ] but
like the [ __ ] that stuck with
me dude homies for life well yeah yeah
because people surprise you in both ways
in your life you can't just be you know
people backstab people and everyone's
been backstabbed and everyone's been
betrayed uh but people also surprise you
the other way too yes and you don't
think about that if you dwell on the
negative yeah but uh the the you know
homies for life if you're if you're my
homie dude yeah that's like I'm you know
I hate to say this dude because people
often say this and they don't mean it
bro but bro I'm built different okay
he's unorthodox right but you just said
I don't like to say this even though
you've been talking about it for 90
seconds straight I'm built different
right when it comes to I'm old school
dude when it comes to
friendships and homies I'm old school
when it comes to friendships and homies
he's unorthodox when it comes to
friendships and homies what you see is
what you get dude if I tell you I'm
there I'm there
right yeah I'm too loud no no I'm just
loud though you're very loud you're
heating up yeah and it's but but that's
annoying right now I had to have
something to do while you were talking
about yourself for so long so do you
think I'm built different in that way
yeah you you are and yeah do you think
that I'm more than I'm unorthodox in
that way I'm so insecure
uh no I think that's a way that a lot of
people are not enough but it's a good
thing to be and it's a way that a good
amount of people are I guess it is
dwindlingly rare right for people to be
that way yeah but they go like this when
they I hear people talking about me I'm
walking by something he is I don't know
if they're dogs
different unorthodox oh that does not
happen but he is with friendships that
does not happen okay I did it I did it I
was walking down the street and somebody
goes I literally heard him built
different ones so you heard none of the
other words friendships
none of the other words I no I didn't
hear the other words
built different don't put friendships
wow I mean that's that's pretty good
guys stop talking about it and they go
no dude I just know that when you're
homies your homies it's thick as the
[ __ ] thickest blood so everyone knows
it about you
I mean yeah okay
okay great great cool okay
okay
uh welcome to Lifeline we've been here
now and we're ready to go yep and I got
my DMX shirt so now the word to go he
has his DMX shirt on I got my [ __ ]
Balenciaga [ __ ] on and we're ready to go
stop so out of breath drop
shot him down open up shop good part oh
whoa good part said I'm not Riders roll
okay are you're so out of breath right
now and and you're good yeah it was I
mean don't like it's hard to do all
those notes don't like burn yourself out
in the first two minutes of the show
right you know you're right all right
cool let's do it all right let's go
hey Chris hey Matt what's up big fan me
and my husband are super huge fans nice
cool we've actually bonded over
listening to congratulations at the
beginning of our relationship
shout out to you Chris
our dilemma that we have we have a
rescue dog his name is Cooper and
um we've had him for a little over a
year now and he actually just bit me for
the second time the other day
and to the point where it drew blood
and um I have had to go to the doctor to
get on antibiotics so that I don't get
an infection from it so my question is
do we keep Cooper and I just steer clear
of him and let my husband do all the
care for him and cuddling and love or do
we try and give him to somebody else
let us know what you think and have them
kill them dude I think honestly it's
crazy how often we do stuff in this
episode and then the first thing is
exactly what we're talking about I was
talking about DMX and this lady is
calling about her dogs that bite
um
do I get credit for that yeah like a
like uh yeah I'm like you're like yeah
yeah yeah
um I think honestly you got to give the
dog out that's crazy the dog drew blood
you're gonna have kids you can't have
the dog around period
I know you have a little bit sorry did
they say they're having kids no no no
but I'm saying if that is in the future
definitely right you gotta get rid of
the dog I mean there's no no I wonder
what
I think what she's implied is that she
the dog has not bitten her husband
I don't know but she if it hurt twice I
know I'm just wondering why that might
be like why it's only biting her because
she's not the alpha I don't know maybe
but certainly could be that yeah yeah
but uh that's weird I mean I'm just
imagining her like holding him upside
down and not realizing it's a bad idea
or something oh well yeah I mean she
shouldn't seem like an idiot but I mean
like she doesn't yeah if you if you can
re-house it in a way that you think is
better for the dog and also better for
the owners
AKA they don't get bit by the dog uh
then yeah sure but I really don't
believe in giving dogs back in general
right you get the dog you get uh giving
it to someone else that you know and
trust is a different thing right because
you're not like throwing it back into
the pool yeah of any go crazy [ __ ]
take it well I think you're saying it
giving it some she said give it to
someone else right so I'm just I'm just
saying if you're gonna give it to
someone else that you know and trust is
going to be a good dog owner then then
yeah do it and then get a dog that's
more docile and gentle and better for
your specific home
um
what's this what am I looking at the
[ __ ] is this why do you bring up Brandon
McMillan
oh you can do a dog training thing yeah
those dogs are beautiful look at that
black dog beautiful right
um yeah that's interesting I have a dog
named Cooper and he couldn't be more
docile so um maybe they could meet
somewhere in the middle and yeah good
dogs together
um yeah I don't know what you do in that
situation I mean look you said husband
if you're planning to have kids you got
to get rid of the dark period like you
can't have a dog that bites people
around your kid that's a [ __ ] yeah
even if it's trained you never know like
what a baby can [ __ ] really upset a
dog real quick oh yeah oh yeah
um but yeah that's a tough spot to be in
uh get you definitely try and get it
trained you can try and do that try to
get the dog trained you know yeah I know
it's money but yeah yeah I mean I would
say do um do all the things that you
could do to try to keep it you obviously
love the dog it sounds like uh and are
trying to come up with the version of
the future where like it only cuddles
and lets your husband pet it that's not
a viable situation but it's not good you
got to have a dog that is compatible
with every person in the house right uh
so
try to get it trained do all the things
you can do and if it doesn't work yes
re-home the dog but don't just put it
back to the shelter or wherever you got
it from
give it to somebody you you know why is
that because
it's a responsibility once you [ __ ]
take in a dog I'm not disagreeing with
it I don't just have give backs you know
right I mean they do that for like you
know shirts that don't fit but okay yeah
but these are living [ __ ] creatures
that you ostensibly love or robots that
the government is implementing
pretending that they're living creatures
just trying to track every move but yeah
no those are just Birds those are only
the parts that the government does that
with
um but yeah uh yeah all right so there
you have it be responsible that's all
yep
let's go here we go hey what's up Chris
and Matt um I need some advice on some
stuff Harry's killing it just working on
making some content creating a couple
lightsabers so dorky okay but I guess
I'm trying to ask today is my girlfriend
and I broke up about a week ago
we're still hanging out
um the reason she broke up with me is
because she wanted to kind of work on
herself and make herself a little bit
better because she's not true to me
super well I mean she was not really
treating me super great but I'm happy
and I was always happy with her
um
but she broke up with me but we're still
hanging out so but I want more from this
but she just doesn't want to put a label
on it should I put an ultimatum on it
should I
try to talk it out a little bit more
with her how many robots she just
doesn't seem super receptive to the idea
of getting back together but she does
want to still hang out and be around me
because she says I'm her favorite person
and that she loves me still so anyways
um could help could uh do well with
advice I mean I'd need it so uh thanks
guys for the podcast just sharpening 900
pencils behind him
if you
if if you are her favorite person
and she loves you
then why the [ __ ] hell isn't she
being your girlfriend
here we go
what's happening
oh
what is happening she's lying so what
what's the truth then
she wants someone else
so what is she doing in the meantime
still hanging out with him
right
cheating oh wow really well yeah dude
she doesn't want to be with him dude if
she doesn't treat him right if she's
feeling guilty about all this [ __ ]
you know I mean I didn't mean to [ __ ]
then she should get the mortar on it
then she should just let it go though
yeah I know but she he look at how
malleable he is you know what I mean
yeah he's just he's like look I'm happy
though I'm happy he's he's making
lightsabers for [ __ ] sake he's easy
going in too many directions yeah dude
you got to get rid of this chick right
yeah it sounds like she is saying [ __ ]
but her actions aren't aligning it I
think he you just need to say and not
worry about don't worry about having the
parachute on the way out of the plane
because sometimes you just gotta go with
the [ __ ] risk but you gotta say hey
if that's true if I'm your favorite
person you don't like hanging out with
anybody else as much as me and you love
me yeah like what are you doing yeah
date me be my girlfriend date me let's
do it horizontally and intertwine our
hearts because you are just trying to
work on your it's the whole thing it's
like that's what you say it's like it's
not you it's me it's like that's what
she's giving him man it's and and and
but then still hanging out I get that if
it's like I'm joking about the cheating
thing I don't know if she's cheating but
she definitely if she doesn't dude when
people want to be with you they just say
no I want to be with you I want to be
with you I don't want to not be with you
if she [ __ ] up she's like I [ __ ] up
I'm sorry but I want to be with you yes
and she's not saying that it's one thing
to
it's one thing to not
treat someone right and it's another
thing to not want to be with them right
like you need to like she she's doing
both of those she's not treating right
and she's not saying she wants to be
with them so those are two things that
you got to be like well I guess I'm
making more lightsabers
because like I'm gonna have some time on
my hands because what you gonna do then
just come to him for some horizontal
Mambo [ __ ] what do you think he should
do though sincerely make more
lightsabers become a [ __ ] businessman
be a f work on yourself she can work on
herself what about hurting yourself what
should he do about her not like what she
do with his life
what's that he's just saying bye bye
everybody he's on a boat dude so he's
your suggestion to him is just nixer
okay but otherwise you're gonna be
stringing along you're gonna be making
some lightsabers bro become a
businessman make multiple lightsabers
create content make the content your
life dude because right now I can tell
dude she's just stringing you along and
you're like okay I don't know uh you
know I'm happy but you're happy bro
because you're passive
okay okay but I would say instead of
just cutting the cord outright
go into a conversation right say all the
things that I was saying before but be
ready for her to give some [ __ ]
excuse and then say
bye-bye totally bye-bye
and Booyah imagine if he did that he
would be my hero but uh but yeah that
that I agree with I agree with Matt and
then be prepared and then do what I did
100 yeah so we got a we got a one-two
Delia punch we got a one-two punch we
got a what Matt said and then what I
said to send it off and what I said is
not less important because at second
it's kind of more like the rounding home
kind of thing so it's even more
important no I would say it's like what
I'm supplying is like 60 to 70 of what's
important you got the tail end 20 you
know no I think it's 60 to 70. we could
say you did 60 for 70 but then I did a
hundred percent so it's like in essence
all of it is 170 that's not how math
works I know but you know well like I
said you design Orthodox you define math
yeah
okay
another one another one blind hey Matt
and Chris I am Anonymous here yeah
Connecticut and I had a question for you
in conversation when I'm talking to my
friends what is this world co-workers
people at church and they share
devastating news bad news and I respond
in empathy saying I'm sorry
they sometimes respond oh it's not your
fault right
and I know it's not my fault but I'm
just trying to be nice and show empathy
and I feel like they're the idiot but am
I the idiot and what should I say if I
keep hearing that response from people
because it boils my blood I love you
guys I watch your historical documents
all the time AKA you're older podcast
and absolutely love you alright thanks
bye okay dude this is what we this is
what you do
hey uh say something my dog doctor my
cat say my cat my cat died I'm sorry
so it's not your fault yes it is and
then stop dude that's a great uh thing
to end the tension right but really
though yes it is what do you do though
for real
it's a it's not it's not your fault yeah
that is a weird [ __ ] thing for people
to say people also how many people have
devastating news around you at church
you know I mean that's the place to go
with devastating news
uh what the [ __ ] though how many people
are that's what I'm saying yeah how many
verse it is a thing people say about how
often are you saying it and having that
response maybe you're the per maybe
she's the person she has that face that
people go to for like oh man you know
right but then I'm sorry is such a
universally understood thing it's like
it's empathize this is what you're
supposed to say that it's not like
apologize oh my cat died oh I'm sorry
yeah me too
yeah yeah it sucks but also also you
know what all you have to do all you
have to do to the anonymous woman here
all she has to do is say I'm sorry to
hear that
oh that blocks it yeah sorry to hear
sorry to hear that and they would but
you know that you can try to jump on you
I'm sorry to hear that you've
destabilized oh that's good advice you
killed it right there and that blocks it
yeah immediately you block that [ __ ]
that's like what do you call it um the
um
what do you call those things that you
take
anti-uh
what do you call those [ __ ] things
what do they do what yeah beta blockers
yeah that's it dude yeah and anti you
know I just created a bit of Blocker of
the of the conversation beta blocker of
the heart beta blocker of the Mind beta
blocker of the combo beta blocker of the
conversation
is what it is oh okay okay well I said
what I said but yeah I mean I pretty
much said beta block off the combo but
yeah I am well yeah okay people often
say uh annoying [ __ ] like that though
and that's just life my baby and you
gotta [ __ ] trudge through the the the
you know the mire the what the muck and
the mire yeah what's Meyer
uh Randy Myers the pitcher wow I don't
know is that what that meant oh all
right I know oh you know it I know it
doesn't be the buck and the Randy Myers
oh you know everything huh no but anyway
uh boggy ground it means see boggy
ground and I knew that Wade boggsy all
right wow so such a baseball
nut now a word from our sponsor better
help
therapy is the best man therapy
I don't even know where I'd be without
therapy uh and frankly uh more people
should be doing it and that might mean
you uh I promise you if you don't have
therapy in your life get it in your life
mark my words it will be a better life
speaking of better how about better help
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists available 100 online
plus it's actually affordable unlike my
therapist just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking with that
therapist you can easily switch to new
therapist anytime it could not literally
could not be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searches for the
right therapist it's all on a platter
right there for you buy better help
learn more and save 10 of your first
month at betterhelp.com
Lifeline that's betterhelp h-e-l-p
dot com slash Lifeline the holidays are
here the holidays are here it is the
season of giving people things we are
popping our merch all over the place
thank you thanks to ship station ship
station is the bomb as uh my mom says
the most wonderful time of the year is
also the most hectic Time of the Year
everyone puts off shopping until the
last minute I know I do and if you have
an online store you know the feeling of
getting hit with a ton of orders all at
once when you're buried in orders and
emails from stress customers you will
wish you had ship station ship station
turns holidays ship storms into smooth
sailing so you can keep your customers
happy and still find time to enjoy some
eggnog
shipstation Keeps Us prepared for
Lifeline drops and the holiday season
for our merch everybody loves ship
station over 130 000 companies have
grown their e-commerce businesses with
ship station and 98 of companies that
stick with ship station for a year
become customers for life baby faux life
this holiday season give yourself the
gift of stress-free holiday shipping use
the promo code Lifeline today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code lifeline
been messing around with this girl for
the past couple of weeks with her one
night after we went to the bars after
school
um went back to her place she was with
her boyfriend that night too oh but he
was in her room and I was kind of on the
couch with her oh boy so the catch is
that she does have a boyfriend he knows
me I know him we're not friends like
that I think she likes me more than I
thought so ever since that night we've
been hanging out kind of on the low
um pretty much doing everything when it
comes to hooking up she's asked me to
hold it while I even pee so oh God
pretty bizarre we've done the horizontal
Mamba a couple of times but she started
crying after and stopped it short
because she claims she feel guilty so
she claims she isn't cheating and her
boyfriend doesn't treat her right but
she keeps going back to him even though
she will talk to me as well so it's it's
calmed down a bit but the question I
have for you guys is do I keep talking
to her or do I kind of just leave her
alone and let the situation play out oh
this is a nice nightmare dude this is a
dude yeah bring up the conversation
until you're not gonna see it anymore
when she's holding your penis while
you're peeing be like
also what do you do with your hands if
she's you never had someone hold your
pee while you're pee or your penis yeah
yeah I've had that yeah yeah
um
so the truth comes out you know my
my agent used to do it
um I
I don't know because in there
um no but yeah I think that that's
absolutely uh uh I mean this is a
[ __ ] Travis this is a debacle right
what's he doing yeah well you know what
he's doing you know what he's doing he's
making trouble no you know what he's
doing being a guy he's being a young guy
yeah yeah but uh it's bad you know it's
bad that's why you called in right but
uh it's uh man you gotta uh also you
know the guy oh yeah hey you went into
his house and you did it with her yeah
and he was sleeping in the room what are
you doing dude this is you're you know
what dude you're gonna end up dead
that's what this is yeah no that's
you're gonna end up dead so she and then
he's gonna do it yeah definitely I mean
this is absolutely insane I don't know I
know guys get in situations like this
where it's just like yeah man but it
just you know it felt too good
had to had to yeah look I I get it yeah
he's gonna get killed you're right uh
this is the kinds of things people kill
people over oh yeah the two things that
people kill people over are Love and
Money yes and this is about [ __ ] love
well when men get like their ego bruises
when they kill people oh dude when you
get your ego bruised over love forget it
dude
us don't say you no not you you said you
you the proverbial you no not it's it's
not that common I'm saying there are
certain [ __ ] though yeah that
haul off and can't control their [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] kill you and it sounds
like this guy is one of those guys he's
gonna kill you dude yeah I mean you're
gonna have a fun a [ __ ] gun talking
to you dude I mean this is just
ridiculous dude yeah you're you're gonna
how about this dude you're gonna die
yeah all right so you should call it off
yeah call it off bro also you did the
horizontal Mambo right also anytime
you're doing a horizontal Mamba with
somebody and then they start crying
that's the last time yeah you can't be
doing that that's the last time dude
it's not a good sign under any
circumstance that is not a good it's
like you're doing [ __ ] don't stand
[Music]
I'll see you later forever
it's been fun high five the guy on the
way up
[Music]
sorry bro didn't even really know you
like that yeah that was what does he
mean by that didn't I yeah I know I
don't really know him like that he's
kind of my friend but I don't really
know him like that okay what I mean is I
don't really know him like that what I
mean by that is
um I know him but not well enough to not
[ __ ] his girl in his house
I'm the worst guy
uh I don't know he hasn't given any
reason to not
like end it like he's not like I really
like her like she's just yeah she's just
around yeah he's just doing a horizontal
Mamba bro so then if that's all it is
absolutely stop it if you if you really
love her though and you want to be like
with her yeah now look still you're
gonna end up dead but try to [ __ ] you
know be like look I want to be with you
yes gonna end up dead anyway yeah but
you know at least go out with love right
what you could also say if you really do
like her say this boyfriend you
obviously not not that into him yeah why
don't you break up with him and we can
date yeah instead of cheating on him why
don't you be with me and cheat on me
because that's gonna happen no well no
maybe she's into him maybe she is but
she obviously is feeling well look she's
conflicted you need to get it right with
her you need to talk with her yes and
say what's going on if you don't want to
do that then it's within your right to
Just Bounce bro I mean she's the one
with the boyfriend yes you don't really
owe her anything yes and I you know I
mean if you want to be a good guy you
maybe say like look I can't do this
anymore but bro look I've seen you you I
can tell your energy and you're not
gonna do that you're not a good guy yeah
um yeah dude I mean if you want to
change and become a good guy
then these things are on the table right
we know that you're not a good guy so
it's in your best interest just to
Simply end it with her and either way
let me just be totally fine either way
your life's gonna end very soon you're
going to be you're gonna be killed yeah
either way dude you're gonna have guns
talking to you yeah yeah I mean they're
just gonna [ __ ]
yeah pick pick those [ __ ] you know
those ones with just a pick pick here's
what you're all going to be having a
conversation if you love your friends
and family stay away from them yeah
because they might catch a stray bullet
yeah dude yeah they didn't want to have
a conversation with some [ __ ] weapons
no right but all of a sudden because of
your love triangle yeah your family's
gonna have a conversation with some
weapons yeah right they didn't want that
right that's why they didn't want the
guy to talk to him that's why he should
respect them and stay far away how am I
talking to something that's four pounds
right yeah right because because the
only thing that's four pounds is a baby
and they don't understand English and
how to speak it oh look a Glock is four
pounds too Pat right in his face okay do
you understand what I'm saying I mean I
do yeah I'm hanging on by a thread
understanding because this guy is
basically making the other guy think an
obsessive thought which is I really
don't want to have to [ __ ] pull out
something from my draw that weighs four
pounds
why are you getting hung up on the
weight of the thing it's just a [ __ ]
nice way to talk about it then okay dude
a gun's four pounds there are there's a
four pound burner you know what I mean
oh okay I don't know you'd sound like
you don't know but I have no idea okay
yeah but it you know if it was four
pounds it's hilarious and I'm very funny
if that is true what's a four pound gun
oh Mill spin beef Jones is what it goes
24 ounces 300
5.8 pounds oh word up
oh okay so then oh how how heavy is a
Glock 19 go ahead right there but first
right there
fully loaded Glock 19.
oh [ __ ] two pounds that doesn't sound
doesn't sound right what what gun is
four pounds just do that wow just want I
want it to fit in my should be right you
know
desert Eagle's four pounds okay so I was
talking about the candidate maneuver
dude I I said Google something and he
didn't do it dude yeah he did oh it is
oh yeah that Desert Eagle bro
you don't want that [ __ ] you don't
want that dry bird coming at you right
speak in your language wow
you don't want that [ __ ] you know
you're yelling
[Laughter]
just [ __ ]
ah and Eddie's [ __ ]
oh I know you like this part oh and then
that [ __ ] dry bird just coming up
right behind you speaking to you dude
you don't want that right no
nobody wants a massive dry bird behind
them speaking to them oh man I love this
so much and I love you dude and this is
so great but I sure hope I I sure I sure
hope that no [ __ ] four pound dry bird
is behind pop Brian the famous last
words
the four pound dry Bird yeah all right
good four pound driver that'll be that
the four pound dry bird all right
next one
hi Matt hi Chris
um Curtis Lauren from Curtis Chucky hell
yeah
um
I have a problem fully forgot who she is
so my fiance and I bought a cutting
board oh boy from Home Goods love this
one so far
um around Halloween so it has a design
of a Ouija board what what so
we go to
um
Florida
Halloween Horror Nights continuously my
mother is watching our kids at our house
so I get
ridiculous amount of messages about how
terrible
this
Ouija board
cutting board yes wow and how she threw
it out oh my God broke it and she
doesn't want to be in our house what
because
oh that's citation
I know it more than you you're not
detector for that but more than you I
finally got your
types and taught her to leave I got
somebody else to watch my kids oh my God
yeah
um because obviously she wasn't
comfortable in my house Kentucky
the family is on me because on you
I told my mother to leave and how dare I
could come over
well they agree with her that's so crazy
I'm at this point Kentucky yeah
it's a Halloween decoration
and it doesn't mean that much to me and
I mean I don't care to get rid of the
Ouija board this is the best
um she's talking to herself now yeah at
this time
I thought forgot she was doing video I
thought she was talking on face time
with her husband right with her fiance
how nobody else realizes how silly that
is okay
so dude
should I throw it out uh dude you know
definitely do not throw it out hang it
up dude put it on the front door hang it
up make it the bottom of the part your
knockoff yeah you know and then when the
mother comes but when your mother comes
by says what the hell why is this here
it goes like this oh my God I didn't put
that there yeah that's so good yeah and
you when you were having a conversation
with her
and she was like I gotta leave I can't
believe you ever satanic thing she
should have been like Mom it's fine it
was just a decoration
from the underworld dude that would have
been unbelievable yeah and she would she
would have believed it for sure oh yeah
dude if she believed that she'll believe
that also
so terrible the grandma dude left the
kid high and dry for the [ __ ] Satan
to come get him
I don't understand dude that is how
[ __ ] stupid you could be
how like taken with just
the dumbest ideology you can This
Woman's obviously in her 60s yeah at the
at the youngest the youngest
this [ __ ] needs to know better
you can't be that crazy anymore people
yeah Natasha grew up
it's how she grew up but she's 16 now
she has no excuse well but I'm saying
that it was indoctrinated in her head
that that's what it was dude some people
think that [ __ ] Halloween is like
legitimately like a a time where people
like get their souls stolen you know wow
and that just doesn't freebar news
yeah I mean people are [ __ ] crazy the
thing is never get rid of it now they've
done something where you can't get rid
of it you need to on principle I guess
keep it I mean it's or she seems
actually this this lady seems so chill
that she's just like if I just get rid
of it I won't have the headache and I I
get that dude I get that like it doesn't
it it's annoying it typically your
stress level you're dealing with this
pretty well I think like she's just like
pretty blase about it probably it
probably is a bigger issue than you're
making it out you know what to do what I
know what to do throw it away but
anonymously send
all different kind of Ouija board [ __ ]
to your mom's house I think that's a
great idea like in the mail and also
like because you're going to be there
sometimes you can like leave stuff under
the couch where it's poking out a little
bit she finds it yep scare the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of her because you can and
because she's [ __ ] crazy and because
she's stupid and because she deserves it
she she's just people yeah you need to
start having more fun with life dude
yeah dude I mean it's annoying flip it
on its head dude this is the spin move
mentality that we talk about just spin
it on its ass yeah right yeah dude I
mean just honestly throw the Ouija board
away and do not speak all this no
um hurting your neck hurting your neck I
think it's pretty wild man that people
believe in that [ __ ] I mean you know
like people like like toast will pop up
and they're like oh the Virgin Mary is
burned in it Yep this this whole house
is religious we need to make it a church
the whole house is religious like it's
just absolutely insane like it's fine to
believe in religion I don't give a [ __ ]
dude and you know like who am I to say
there's no God I have no [ __ ] idea
like I don't know either way sure but
like to be that [ __ ] sure about it it's
about that about that is absolutely I
bought it from [ __ ] Home Goods yeah
well that you know demonic entities yeah
sure yeah Home Goods wow wow
Home Goods yeah what do you think about
that I think that the moment you have a
child you love going to Home Goods
the moment you have possess a single
child
you instantly love to shop at Home Goods
you know what I'm saying yeah I mean I
mean Kristen loved Home Goods no matter
what but now that Calvin's around really
she's it's home good Central she's the
mayor of homes good thing Home Goods
dude she's the mayor of Home Goods and
the [ __ ] and the and the governor of
Target
oh oh I mean just she's got into
politics huh yep I didn't know that I
will increase chachki spending by 100
if elected governor of Target this is
Kristen I will increase
ceramic Angel spending
ceramic angels and also
really anything you could really want
because target has everything I will
increase spending
spending 100 percent
yeah she doesn't sound anything like
that what is that
you know I don't know I just picked an
accent it's like your QVC voice yeah it
was I was in the middle and I could try
to back off it yeah wow he's got Tricks
in his bag and he's getting exposed uh
all right cool well uh we could do
another one
he's getting exposed what's up Chris and
Matt what's up Chris huge fan saw you in
Atlanta don't know what date
dates like guys go see him he was
hilarious and thanks for introducing me
to Matt as well oh yeah um so guys I
need advice on something
I am somebody that really struggles with
uh discipline like self-discipline
um I just if I don't want to do
something I have a really hard time
doing it even if I know I need to I'm
just I don't do it and I will and if I
do I complain the entire time and I know
it's something that I really need to
change and get better at so what's your
advice for how to like be more
self-disciplined and you know get [ __ ]
done
um do I need to like run a marathon or
something
um
any advice would be appreciated love you
guys thanks advice for yourself yeah I
mean I hate doing [ __ ] I'll run a
marathon only if running a marathon is
one of those things that you've been
avoiding forever that you need to do you
said you'd suffer from it too dude
you're disciplined but here's the thing
here's how I stopped being like that the
the I was like that oh but I realized
once I started actually taking care of
[ __ ] the amount that the of anxiety that
was nagging at me to do that [ __ ] was
way worse than the experience of doing
any of the things that I was anxious
about putting off so it's like damn
doing it you're saving yourself from
anxiety so once you realize that
doing the thing becomes a better option
than the alternative and because the
more you get into the habit of that the
more true it becomes okay so I hear what
you're saying and I I understand what
you're saying and you think ahead and
that's great but how about this dude
what about somebody who says this to
that but I don't wanna
and say okay but then she's stuck still
well that's her [ __ ] problem isn't it
um
it's tough to be disciplined man
sometimes I imagine I go like this [ __ ]
I gotta I gotta work out right I don't
want to but in my head if I want to and
I know I'm gonna do it it's practically
already done
because
time is irrelevant and I know that it's
going to be done so it's practically
done if I know I'm gonna do it it's
that's like 50 of the whole thing so do
you end up doing it yeah then I'll end
up doing it okay then yeah yeah I know
it's done because I already decided to
do it it's practically tomorrow and how
do you think this applies to her because
you know if you have to do [ __ ] she's
disciplined whatever say she's a
whatever a writer and she's got to write
a manuscript or some [ __ ] she thinks I
gotta write three pages today I have to
do that by 8 pm
I already did it basically
um because I already chose to do it
that's interesting yeah I do that
sometimes and it works man so then what
is the thing that
gets you to actually do it is it the
fact that you have you can't you can't
let a thing not happen that you've
already decided has happened yeah you
make decisions in life and if you've
made the decision it's already done
you're not deciding maybe I'll do that
you've decided I'm going to do that
that's going to be done today so
therefore it's done because I made the
decision right and so the fear of going
back on this lessons Okay yeah yeah it
actually works it's a [ __ ] weird
thing and I'm basically a life coach
that's one of the smarter things I've
ever heard you say
um you don't say a lot of smart things I
do I do and that's the crazy thing about
it is and you realize that no I don't
and no I don't think that I've decided
that you realize that and so basically
it's already done
that's good that's good advice too so
both equally good advice that we gave
yeah so I wish I knew what your whole
thing is you were struggling with or
what you're discipline you know maybe
it's chores maybe it's doing the dishes
right but I [ __ ] did this last night
my sense is this like going on
it's okay with issue you will issue you
in oops but it's fine
it's like going my sense is like it's
going to the doctor going to the dentist
[ __ ] like that but I could be wrong I
did it going back on what I said before
you're really interesting but like
before I [ __ ] throw out an oops right
please do
um is
it it basically I did it with the
ditches last night I knew I had to do it
and I thought I don't want to do it
because who the [ __ ] wants to do the
dishes right and I thought
you know what when I go to bed The
Bishop's the bishes the [ __ ] when I
go to bed them [ __ ] when I go to bed
the dishes will be done therefore
they're done I've decided and I did it
and I did it and it was a lot easier
because I knew it was going to be done
as I was doing it
he plays tricks on his own I like that
no it's he plays tricks on his own mind
we got to once we realize how faulty our
own brains are we got to play tricks on
them he's playing tricks
dude this pocket is a musical
uh not the gangster version the [ __ ]
cleaning dishes version Oh you know that
song No you don't know that song no mama
playing tricks on me
so then you lie but you said plan
something about doing dishes it's
obviously don't talk about doing dishes
okay well then I don't know it this year
Halloween came on a weekend or whatever
the [ __ ] that song is one of the
greatest hip-hop songs of all time
yeah that sounds great is there two
though there's one the regular one and
the other one is about no the one I was
making that up now as a joke so there's
only one there's one and then I I guess
you could argue that I created a new one
right now but okay
until the beginning of this show there
was only one episode
I mean you can't Google you can only
Google one but at this point after this
food song after this yeah maybe somebody
will make a remix about the doing dishes
one right but I made that up right I
want the credit right you should get at
least 15 I'm the writer of it I'm not
the [ __ ] I didn't make the music of
it but I'm a writer of it right right
um but that song is awesome have you
seen the music uh maybe forever ago yeah
he's punching on the dude and then he
realizes he's just punching on the
concrete oh yeah yeah dude wow
[Music]
so sexy the way you're doing it
I [ __ ] fight being so sexy but you
what it almost makes it more sexy oh I
see
like ask me if I'm sexy are you sexy no
and you're saying that makes you sexy
yeah all right all right so let's do
another one sure
um and also congrats on your cute kid
Calvin he's amazing thank you to myself
just found out why I was pregnant with a
third yes dude yes um but this kind of
brings me my question and my advice is
that I need so I've been working for uh
I'm an accountant I'm a CPA working for
my uncle-in-law for seven years told him
I want to do my own thing he wants me to
pay for clients that he was just gonna
give away for free
um and I don't agree with that but I
don't want to burn any Bridges as long
as I want to do what's best what does
that mean now I'm pissed you paused it
what does that mean pay for clients that
he was going to get for free what does
that mean like he was gonna turn clients
away
and he was gonna just do that because he
couldn't fit him in yeah and now he
wants a cut of it for sending those
clients to him or they were clients of
the uncle in-laws and he was maybe
managing them and now he wants to break
off and do his own thing and take those
clients with him and the uncle wants to
wants a cut of it he wants either a cut
of it or just pay him a fee for taking
those clients well that would make more
typical it's just kind of yeah that
would make it more typical it's not
atypical for that to happen no that's
normal what I'm saying would not be
normal how do you know that's normal
or like any sort of agencies that do
this like do they yes yeah okay I don't
know that yeah okay you're being so
hostile you know I know nothing about
but well the answer is yes we keep
saying yes but but you're not a lawyer
and [ __ ] and you're not good but I'm
also not a [ __ ] evolutionary
biologist I can tell you about [ __ ]
so we come for monkeys I
yeah why they're still monkeys okay
solid anyway in my family
um and do it respectfully but part of me
is like I've had seven years of
shoveling [ __ ] and I'm kind of tired of
it yeah do I just go in there give them
the spin move and say taking these
clients with me didn't sign any
non-compete best of luck or do I try to
approach him and say hey I don't agree
with with paying you for these and
here's why either way I would appreciate
whatever you guys got thank you so much
and uh love the podcast peace
he was right about what it is right and
uh
I think the latter is the one he should
do to go in and ask him about it and
talk to him yeah and if he gives you any
kind of hostility or pushback be just
get drop the hammer
because if you've got the hammer in your
back pocket why you waste it up front
except well I'll tell you why okay
because you you know it's better to You
could argue that it's better to appear
firm in your beliefs and strong and be
like yo I'm not doing this
period
and then because because here's the
thing there's wiggle room the other way
is all and I'm not saying that this is
the right thing to do those are the two
options that you you should definitely
explore but if you if you go in and you
say hey so here's why I think this and
that then that guy well this and that
and this and that and then you might
work out to something that isn't just
you may have to compromise but if you go
in and you say Hey listen I didn't sign
anything it's been seven years of me
working for this I want to go off on my
own these clients are more comfortable
with me you aren't going to use them
anyway so I'm going to take them and I
don't feel like I owe you anything and
that's just how it's going to be
it you know do you know what I'm saying
and you don't let him get a word in
about it well he can say whatever he
wants but this is what's happening right
I mean he can just do that right yeah if
he didn't sign a non it's just right
it's just then then yeah it's weird for
family to do that like if somebody Who
You're
you know he yeah family's different all
across the world but I I I would never
do that too like if you were gonna be
like okay just take them yeah that is
very strange maybe he should drop the
hammer up front yeah I've been I've been
convinced yeah it is kind of weird that
the family that that you know it is his
uncle-in-law so who knows how real close
they are like family wise I didn't even
hurt uncle-in-law but no uncle in law is
like uh Vinnie the Christian no I know
what it is okay but but it's just I've
never heard I would just say uncle or a
guy I know or maybe he's testing him
yeah that's right that's right which is
another thing because then it's like you
gain respect yeah to be like dude do
what he said yeah you did it right yo
I'm not gonna pay you and here's why and
the guy goes like this wow the the
student really surpassed the teacher
yeah and that's who my niece should be
with yeah he just gets up and yep
that's what he does yeah for his for his
uh yeah I don't think nephew is really a
bad a bad thing yeah could we figure
that out
that's great do we do one more we uh
settled okay cool but we're just settled
up uh
uh uh we appreciate you guys uh you know
what I tell you this man I'm gonna be in
San Diego I'm gonna be in Lakeland
Florida Daytona and I'm also going to be
in uh Jacksonville and I'm gonna be in
Portland and Seattle and uh and New York
New York and Chicago and Minneapolis and
Austin go to chrisley.com get your
tickets I got a question for you okay
what's your favorite
City to perform in
it might be Boston really it might be
Minneapolis it might be
it might be Toronto wow I also love
performing in Los Angeles well yeah but
you know but no no because you know the
Crowds Are tougher but I really like you
know getting them yeah uh
I mean dude if you're in a really big
city and you're a successful comedian
it's all pretty much the same but
there's something about Boston that's
really great really yeah because
they're smart and they're not too
they're a mix of the right and the left
and they appreciate the edginess
and they're just a great they're great
crowds but it constantly changes man
like you know but I think Boston I would
I would have a hard time saying Boston
is not top three just throughout my
career
Chicago's usually great
um I didn't expect Boston yeah did you
not no what would you have thought I've
heard Boston's like the hardest City to
play in for uh like in sports because of
because the fans are [ __ ] yeah but I
you know once you build your fan base
life in Boston is like from what I can
gather is it's very like
um
you know Boston people from Boston think
Boston's the [ __ ] best yes and uh
that could be annoying for people to do
that okay but it's just I don't know
like Boston is [ __ ] awesome uh and
like weirdest the one major American
city I've never been to yeah that is
good but it is kind of one of those
cities that's like why would you go
unless you wanted to see New York for a
while yeah but why I never went to
Boston yeah true yeah because you could
drive right yeah I went to [ __ ] DC
went all over but never went to
Boston is one of those never went to Old
Beantown you know what I'm saying yeah
we don't like that you say Beantown but
um yeah I love Boston dude like I I
bleed green okay well yeah let's not I
do [ __ ] and I'm a big fan of the
Celtics
[Laughter]
um yeah I love Boston but yeah there's a
lot of great cities I can't leave out
like you know a [ __ ] love performing
in Vancouver I love Austin I love it I
didn't ask you to list every city in
Houston is banging Dallas is the [ __ ] DC
is great I mean wow big cities are
awesome okay
uh Boston's your answer but I would say
not right now boss is my answer yeah uh
go to watch lifeline.com if you have a
question like a submission if you have a
submission for a submission you get on
the [ __ ] show go to watch
lifeline.com lifelinemerch.com Lifeline
merch lifelinemerch.com get pimpin
pimpin get it for the holidays get it
for yourself get it for your family get
it for your friends or you [ __ ] hate
us and now the big one one-on-one advice
with me Mr Matt Delia go to mattelia.com
and book me baby Tuesdays and Thursdays
all afternoon at your disposal
hello hello hello hello
[Music]